شجعني ان انا اتكلم في موضوع اخر
ولا انا حضور كريم من قاده العالم
لهذا المؤتمر
اكبر حجم
معذره يعني من القاده قاده الدول الملوك
ورؤساء ورؤساء حكومات موجودين الان معنا
عشان نناقش مشكله كبيره جدا
بتقابلنا
وهتقابلنا لكن انا هاتكلم معكم النهارده
اتكلم كده في موضوع اخر
هو نداء احنا محتاجين
نتحرك نعمل
ندعو
لي
انا باتكلم على ازمه كبيره بتمر بالعالم
ولها تاثير كبير جدا على دول كثير من
العالم اللي ما كانش كل دول العالم انا
بتكلم تحديدا هنا على الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
وباوجه نداء
سمحتوا لي
بكم ومعكم من اجل ان تتوقف هذه الحرب
من اجل ان تتوقف هذه الحرب
من فضلكم
نحن
كدول
اقتصادها
مش قوي
عن الكثير جدا من تبعات
ازمه كرونه سنتين
وتحملناها
والان معاني ايضا من هذه الحرب
ولكن انا بتكلم هنا عشان العالم كله اتصور
انه بيعاني من هذه الحرب انا باقول ثاني
احنا مستعدين انا بنادي باسمكم واسمي ان
سمحتوا لي كده
ان احنا فلتتوقف هذه الحرب هذا نداء من
مؤتمرنا هنا ان سمحتوا لي بكده
الدمار وهذا القديم بالمناسبه احنا
مستعدين
بالمناسبه انا مستعد ومش
مش للبحث عن دور لا والله ولكن من اجل
العمل
كثير من القائد الموجودين يشاركون الرائده
احنا مستعدين نتحرك اذا كان ده ممكن
لايقاف هذه الحرب